So now we're going to
try plotting a world
map with a new data
set that has the number
of international students
from each country.
So first of all,
we're going to need
to use the ggmap package,
which you may need to install.
And we're going to
load in the data
set, which is
called intlall.csv.
So read.csv(intlall.csv).
And I'm going to do
stringsAsFactors = FALSE.
OK?
Let's look at the first
few rows of intlall.
So you see that each row
corresponds to a country.
There's a citizenship
column that's
the country name, number
of undergraduates, number
of graduates, special
undergraduates and graduates,
exchange or visiting,
and a total column.
Now there's these NAs in here,
but they're not really NAs.
They're just 0's.
So what we're
going to do is say,
all these NAs should be 0's.
So in intlall, all entries
that are NA, should be 0.
And let's look at the
first few rows again.
OK.
Much better.
Right, so next step is
to load the world map.
So let's call it world_map
= map_data("world").
We did something similar in the
lecture with the state data.
So let's look at the
structure of the world_map.
So the first two columns are
the longitude and latitude;
third column is
something called group --
that's actually a
group for each country,
using a different number
for each country; order,
we'll get to that later; region
is just the country name,
and subregion is sometimes used
for some countries to describe
islands and other
things like that.
So we want to shove
the world_map data
frame and the intlall data
frame into one data frame,
so we can use it for ggplot.
So let's say world_map is a
merge of world_map and intlall.
Now, in world_map,
the country name
is just called region, as
you can see right here.
And in the intlall,
the country name
is actually called Citizenship.
OK.
So let's look at the
structure of world_map
just to make sure
it makes sense.
Looks good.
OK.
So to plot a map, we use
the geom_polygon geometry.
So start off ggplot(world_map,
aes(x = long, y = lat,
group = group)).
We want to use geom_polygon
as the geometry.
Countries will be
filled in in white,
and their borders
will be in black.
And we'll use a
Mercator projection.
There's a few other
options in there, as well.
OK.
So that looks kind
of like a world map.
There's a few things
going on here.
So first of all,
all the countries
look like big black blobs.
What on earth is going
on, you might say.
Well, sometimes the merge
can reorder the data.
And it turns out that what the
world_map data frame really is
is actually a list of
latitude and longitude points
that define the border
of each country.
So if we accidentally
reorder our data frame
they no longer make any sense.
And as it goes from
point to point,
the points might be on the
other side of the country
as it defines the polygon.
So, we have to reorder the
data in the correct order.
So this command is a little
bit complicated looking,
but when you break it
down, it's not so bad.
So, we take the world_map,
and we're going to reorder it.
So world_map, we're going
to reorder the rows.
We're going to order
the rows based on, first
of all, the group,
which is pretty much
equivalent to the country, and
then the order variable, which
is just the correct order
for the border points.
And we're going to take
all the columns, of course.
Done.
So if we go and try plotting
it again -- so ggplot--
I guess I should go up, up.
There we go, much easier.
Right, so now we
have the map, and it
looks far more reasonable.
OK, next problem.
Some of the countries
are missing.
Now of course,
the USA is missing
because MIT is in
the USA, so that
wouldn't be an international
student coming from the USA.
And some parts of Africa
are missing, presumably
because there are no
students at MIT right now
who are from those countries.
But you'll also notice
that Russia is missing,
and a lot of countries
near it, as well as China.
Which is definitely
not true because I
have many friends at MIT who
are from Russia and China.
So, what do we do about that?
The reason China is
missing is that it
has a different name
in the MIT data frame
than in the
world_map data frame.
So when we merged
them, it was dropped
from the data set because
it didn't match up.
So to see what it's called
in the MIT data frame,
let's just do a table.
There's a few ways to do
this, but this is pretty easy.
OK, so we get a list
of all the names.
If we scroll all
the way up, we'll
see it says "China
(People's Republic Of)".
Now, in the
world_map data frame,
it's simply called "China".
So, what we can do is
change the MIT data frame.
So let's say the citizenship
column, the one row where
it equals "China
(People's Republic Of)"
should just be "China".
OK, let's check.
Do the table again.
Scroll all the way up.
There it is, China.
So we've fixed that.
So now the MIT data frame is
consistent with the world_map
data frame.
So now we have to go
through the merge again.
So let's say
world_map is a merge
of a fresh copy of the
map_data, the intlall data
frame with China fixed.
It's called region in
the world_map data,
and it's called Citizenship
in the MIT data.
Alright, now we need to
do the reordering again.
So press up a few
times until we find it.
There it was.
So there's the
reordering command.
OK.
And we should be
good to go, now.
So let's try plotting it.
So ggplot, the
world_map data frame.
The aesthetic, x is the
longitude, y is the latitude.
We need to group
countries together,
so it doesn't all
crisscross over the map.
We're going to use
geom_polygon again.
This time though, let's
actually fill them
with a color that's
proportional to the total number
of students.
We'll still outline
them in black, though.
And we'll use the
Mercator projection.
Much better.
So Russia is missing
for similar reasons,
but we won't deal with that
now because it's a little bit
annoying.
But you get the idea.
This is pretty
interesting actually.
So we can see that Canada,
and China, and India supply
a large number of
international students to MIT.
But it is a little
bit confusing doing it
on a per country basis,
because Europe, presumably,
has quite a few students at MIT.
But because Europe is made
up of many small countries,
it doesn't look very impressive.
Maybe if all the
European countries
were grouped together,
it would look
about the same color as Canada.
But it's hard to tell.
There are also other
projections we can look at.
So this is a
Mercator projection.
What I want to show you is an
orthographic projection that
allows you to sort of view
the map in 3D, like a globe.
So let's try that out.
ggplot, world_map,
aesthetics are the same.
Actually, let me do
this the right way.
I'll just press up.
OK.
Let's change it to
orthographic projection.
And I want to find,
now, an orientation.
And this is almost like thinking
about where in the world
you want to focus on.
So this is a latitude
and longitude, 20 degrees
and 30 degrees.
If we run this, we
should get a map
centered above North Africa.
That's quite a
nice visualization
because if you want to look
just at Africa and Europe,
this is the way to go.
We can still see China,
and Canada, and South
America in there, as well.
Let's do something a
little bit more personal.
I want to change the
coordinates, now,
to -37 and 175.
Now it's centered on my hometown
of Auckland, New Zealand.